[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the final round of voting for the 2022
podcast march madness tournament ended
yesterday if you're already a subscriber
welcome back to joke world but if you're
new here today's video will be recapping
the results of our comedy podcast march
madness tournament started off with over
25 different comedy shows then every
weekend in march you guys voted to see
who would move on through the bracket
now it just so happened that the finals
turned out to be the number one overall
seed joe rogan experience going up
against tom segura christina p and your
mom's house before we get into the
results though it should just be said
that some of the greatest podcast
content of all time especially my
personal favorites have been when these
two guys have gotten on each other's
shows i know some of the best jre
episodes and moments happen with tom on
the show and some of their other friends
like the sober oktober crew and the
highest viewed your mom's house episode
of all time was episode number 397 when
they had joe on would you ever date your
mom
oh definitely not
first of all she's older than me and
second of all she's my mom well why
i'm your mom and you're my son
and i am falling in love with him he
said are you really i said yes i am he
said you know what
i was scared to let you know too i am
too we're both consenting adults if if
it comes down to it you know it's just
like the gays they're they're you know
as long as they're over 18 everything's
fine
you know what i mean the us wants to
jail them for 18 months well that'll fix
it they got arrested they actually got
arrested oh well they should definitely
arrest him where's the [ __ ] if you want
to [ __ ] your mom that's our point
that's true
i don't care i can't i don't care at all
but i think it's that he wants to marry
his mom there comes the legality he's a
[ __ ] yeah she's got a tattoo on her face
yeah you say go for it look once you
have a baby too
your tits get mushy that's it that's
just it's nature so what should i do
should i hoist them up should i have
them reduced don't talk about it first
of all yeah keep that [ __ ] to yourself
or no women are gonna have kids and our
population's going to die off
she's got dogs like three or four dogs
in the yard barking and these coyotes
don't give a [ __ ] did you see that video
where they the pack came into her house
or into her yard yeah there's like six
of them yeah yeah that neighbor that
neighborhood they're sketchy
i told her to get a subsonic 22 and just
start taking them out
she won't she's like
put him down pop pop put a little bait
out there
does this what's like the city rules
about taking out a coyote the city rules
you keep your [ __ ] mouth shut yeah
and just
shoot shovel and shut up
what is it about farts that are so
hilarious it's the best
it's they're never not funny they're
never not entertaining because they're
so taboo you're never supposed to do
them in front of strangers
the smell the sound everything's
everything about it they're sublime and
the other people
the people that love them versus don't
like it i think that's all rooted in if
your household
was okay with farts or not it's class
and we had none growing up so that's why
we're we're euro trash so we loved farts
right poopy's hot was farts was it
talked about in your house was it no no
look how thin you are thank you bastard
i've been working thinner than bert
still i think oh the bird went right
back
did you see
how i mean like
we had
i want to show you this this is like
people would call in
or like send in videos saying bird is
fat in different languages
amazing why is this so fast
[Laughter]
this was amazing people that listen to
the podcast that teach english as a
second language would use
the whole fat battle to teach english
abroad in in different countries
[Applause]
[Music]
and
either he gets a little bit of kibble
and some elk meat
or give him ground elk meat or something
some other kind of meat marshall's
spoiled he as well he eats well that's
awesome dude he's a happy dog yeah i
think everyone loves marshall
have you met him yeah met him you met
him here right couple times yeah he's
the sweetest dog in the world yeah
adorable like i didn't even know the
dogs were like that
yeah no it's a special dog it's uh
golden retrievers man they're smart too
they're real smart i have a [ __ ] box
of sand as a dog but she's adorable
she's sweet but she's dumber than [ __ ]
what is she brussels griffon well i
don't even know what that is it looks
like an ewok
oh oh i do know what that is okay
yeah that's right yeah that's an odd
choice is that your wife's choice of
course yeah yeah frauds they get
sweet little dog but they basically want
a baby that they don't care too much of
it dies
that's a good way of putting it i think
she'd be pretty sad this one died but
yeah she'd be pretty sad but not like
babysat no [ __ ] with no farther or do
let's find out who won this thing so the
poll was live for 24 hours and had
almost 10 000 people vote on it and the
percentages ended up being 66 to 34.
with the joe rogan experience winning
congrats joe congrats young jamie
congrats everyone who voted for the joe
rogan experience you are the winner of
the first ever march madness comedy
podcast tournament i have a little this
then we'll spark up a doob there it is
get the party start cheers brother thank
you october man thank you thank you
i enjoy clips of jre but your mom's
house along with a few others i queue up
straight away to enjoy the full episode
absolutely hilarious obviously that's a
big downfall of current joe rogan is
that you don't get full episodes on
youtube anymore and you do with ymh so
that's a big advantage that they have
there
but i do like to queue up a straight
episode of joe rogan if i'm not a long
drive or something because it can be
interesting even if he doesn't have a
comedian on that week when you think of
podcasts who's the first person you
think of rogan's winning the whole thing
that's also what i'm saying it is kind
of deserved that he might win the first
overall
podcast tournament because he did in a
way invent the comedians having podcast
game um i know mark maron had one early
but when you think of comedians and
making podcasts they all say they're
inspired by rogan they've all been on
rogue and we think of joe i really like
that comment best all-around podcast jre
best comedy podcast ymh uh jre is the
best jack of all trades ymh is
definitely the better comedy podcast a
lot of people saying this and i
completely agree with that you know your
mom's house is intentionally funny every
single time and joe rogan is
occasionally funny especially when he
has um comedians as guests on but there
are still some diamonds in the rough
there
like the post malone
episode that interview is hilarious and
he's not a comedian or the alex jones
episodes are some of the funniest ones
ever and they're hard to see now because
they're censored but those are hilarious
and alex jones isn't a comedian so
sometimes when he doesn't have comics on
it still can be worth watching i
definitely get what you mean i watch a
full episode jerry when it's a suit of
comedians like the episodes of gillis
norman and shafir with ymh i can watch
just the main mommies for hours on end
and not notice there being no guests
that's a huge advantage that your mom's
house has too is that they have two uh
hosts that are both comedians so you can
just have them talk to each other and
it's gonna be just as good as joe having
a comedic guest on two because those are
just two comedians that have some of the
best rapport obviously i mean they're
married with so you know you could yeah
just listen to them talk to each other
for hours there's a ton of people that
love to say joe rogan's not a comedy
podcast but to me i think a comedy
podcast is a podcast that's hosted
by a comedian not necessarily a podcast
that is intending to be funny every
episode because
when joe has on comedians it's obviously
a great time just like when he has tom
on and stuff but when he has on you know
other people there can still be funny
moments it's just not maybe as
intentional as ymh all the real mommies
know the real winner here jerry is dope
but sometimes joe's jeans are low and
loose and tim and christine's are always
high in tight they never touch my camera
through the fence i just sit back take
10 to 12 benadryl and finish in four
strokes amen jeans that's the most ymh
comment of all time had to throw that in
there at the cleveland improv once like
i was that was grinding through a rough
set and this guy in the third row goes
uh he goes
that's terrible man like that like fully
loud like this guy is terrible
what's up man and then some lady in the
back goes your mama should have
swallowed that nut like meaning like is
it cleveland yeah the cleveland improv
wow i was like damn yeah i go your dad
should have stuck around to raise you
and then
and then like i got out of there pretty
quick
there were over 100 comments and the
main theme seemed to be that your mom's
house is clearly the better comedy
podcast and joe rogan is clearly the
most
legendary uh podcast of all time and
maybe the most important but not the
funniest your mom's house is clearly the
best comedy podcast jerry is only funny
when their other comics on this guy said
still can't believe tim dillon didn't
get enough votes i think we all know tim
dillon is the real winner here so
besides the tim dillon fans i can't
believe that he was voted out two rounds
ago the joe rogan experience takes the
first ever win of the comedy podcast
march madness tournament but thank you
to everyone who participated in this we
had over 60 000 people vote between all
the rounds combined so that's some
really cool fan interaction there make
sure you subscribe to joke world if you
haven't already and go check out our
community section for even more polls
and fun questions related to comedy
posting stuff on there all the time and
also go follow us on instagram we're
featuring a new comedian every single
day they send in their best 60 second
stand up clip and we're putting them on
a platform uh to get exposed also if you
dm the instagram you get these free joke
rolled stickers and they're really cool
and everyone who doesn't have a joke
world sticker that's very embarrassing
and kind of lame and like i would not
show my face in public without one of
these stickers so i hope that you don't
either but thanks for watching we'll be
back soon gear yourselves up ladies and
gentlemen 11 months from now join on in
[Music]
you